so here's my velocity function okay it
says the first two times its speed so
speed do I care about sign at the moment
I don't
okay so positive negative done that is
half its maximum speed
now I've already calculated maximum
speed right so for Part C I tried to
solve for B equals sorry
yeah B equals what is that all you told
me not to worry about saying right so in
fact it's plus or minus 5 PI 5 because
if I hit 5 like obviously that's half
but if I hit negative 5 PI that is also
half because it doesn't I don't care
about direction I'm not worried yeah
okay all right so so now that I'm
solving for that okay
it probably would help me them point out
two things number one I say this do you
notice I say this all the time but I
don't launch straight into the equation
I say what I'm trying to solve like I
can't advise that enough secondly I make
a lot of arguments from a graph okay
they've ever asked me or they sometimes
ask me to graph but they sell them they
sell them do okay they might provide
your graphic you're lucky I think you're
kind of kidding yourself to not draw a
graph like it's so hard to wrap your
head around something real add a picture
to look at so this is the piece I'm
interested in now I'm interesting the
velocity function so let's draw a quick
and dirty
what's my energy
ten pie and that means that's they give
ten pie okay so when I have a look this
is really nice when I have a look at
this I have a geometric way to say what
am I trying to solve right - all where
is the first time I hit five pun that
right there's five five cuz it's exactly
half right so I'm going forward in time
a bit and I know by the way what these
times are don't I don't know what the
end point here is a period is 24 seconds
so one of these guys these six and 18
yes okay so good my first answer should
be like about taco six I know I know
it's gonna be between north and six
right where's my next answer okay so I
have to appeal to this right like to
remember us the point of us putting plus
or minus is that I could go to the next
time I hit five pi but all the way over
there but I've hit the whof whof the
maximum speed on one two three times
since then
so here is the second time right here's
the first here's the second so I've got
an answer between Noir and six and I
haven't answered between six and twelve
degree with that so now at least I have
an idea
you know we talked about sense checks
right that was a sense check just there
it was a pretty sense check because I
already know okay I've got rough domain
in which to find solutions okay so now
I'm gonna set up an equation okay if I'm
solving the V equals 5 PI I'm just gonna
let I'm gonna make a substitution over
there right somebody say 10 PI cos yeah
I'm just good divide through by 10 PI
which is me this now if you could have
seen that before right you could have
noticed that because of course you're
gonna be half this just this ignores the
air for two you actually half is
relative to like your top speed might
not have been thirty one point four one
five nine meters it could've been 100
meters per second or 2,000 meters per
second or whatever you're still going to
hit half at the same time
ah you could give me the exact value for
this country I on 12 T equals PI on
three yep do we agree
dude that so I will divide both sides by
PI on 12 which gives me I believe four
yeah does that make sense does that
confirm it does doesn't it have a look
as well what's really nice about the
fact that you've dug your graph here is
you can see oh yeah you're taking a bit
longer to reach that part of the time
right this interval is a bit shorter
than this one but you'll know even
better than me probably because your
graph will be a bit better if you're
using tip up that kind of thing so
fantastic I've got my first outside now
I'm gonna have a look at the second one
and my diagram informs the fact that I
can say he's the first time and now I'm
gonna work out the second time okay so
tell me what your equations are use
words and describe what your equations
are solving I'm now gonna say it 10 pi
cos okay the next line is going to be
the same except for the site right so
I'm gonna end up at this that's you I'm
gonna end up at this point and again
you can give me any tag value for that
don't you
yet
I've heard one answer I don't see a lot
of reality oh yes of course
how do I work this out when you when you
invest cars right your calculators
surely danger it'll hand you clearly a
decimal mess right but it will continue
this because what's the domain of as
opposed to side investments what's the
sort of range of Kosovo's it's not a pie
as it it's not supply and this is from
not a pie
yes okay someone divide through oh yeah
what sided by through eight does that
make sense
so you can see that another way apart
from using positive s and by the way
about answer of course it does make
sense is you can look at the symmetry
here just like we did over here right
have a look let's see if the diagram is
right I said it takes four seconds to do
that right four seconds to do that so
therefore when you have a look at the
gaps right have a look at this gap here
on what's that yeah that's two seconds
right but because of the symmetry of the
cosine quadrant right that two seconds
is the same as that two seconds isn't it
so when you go down to here that's when
you should hit negative 5 PI meters per
second for the first time so 6 plus 2
that will give you 8 at that point which
can if your graph is good enough to make
it argue it off which I expected to the
earth go to the page you can you refer
to it that kind of thing you can take
the symmetry of you know this is this
value here is 6 minus 2 so the x value
is 6 plus 2 then absolutely yes you can
but I will point out most people's
graphs are not good enough to do that
you have a look at my graph my graph is
the size of an a 3-page that's why it's
so easy to make the argument of it this
of course by the way I'll point out was
an arduous it wasn't hard
like you always hoped it was pretty
quick in fact so I don't think there's
any reason to necessarily avoid that